yes but you've got to hit frozen movies
will there be a third one more than that
I love this franchise listen even this
is my Star Wars okay even though I have
zero Authority and no control I would
like to formally announce frozen three
four and five and I just want easy to
hear that that I'll be showing up
[Applause]
let's do it yes attack no control but I
would like to formally announce it yeah
you know what you all should do - they
always do this sometimes the Hollywood
Bowl I feel like where you don't even
have to they stand behind like you know
Mike's never ins kind of acting out the
characters yeah should do that we have
talked about this because there's
because between the music from the first
one in the second one that we all know
and love and there's a couple songs that
have been cut that no one's ever heard
from the first one and the second one
we've been talking about maybe doing
like the Hollywood Bowl maybe televising
it perhaps next year with all of our
Jonathan and it didn't invite us fine if
you want it okay got it got to attend I
can I can help I can be where all black
and work the stage I mean I really just
want to be there okay I love when they
do that cuz yeah he loves the music it's
a big part of it I will not stop talking
until you subscribe to my YouTube
channel that's right and I could talk a
lot seriously not gonna stop yep still
here not going anywhere I see you don't
walk away from this